i started watching these videos i was
bored one night and i clicked you know
how the algorithm gets you sometimes
you know and i saw this guy on the
thumbnail how important is the thumbnail
i saw this guy on the thumbnail in a
[ __ ] cockpit and he was like this
but not with his hand but his lip was
down and it looked like wind was blowing
him and it was like geforce pass out
compilation videos and i just go oh i'm
good for two hours
i'm good dude let me just sit back
kick my feet up and relax and just watch
these pilots
pass the [ __ ] out
while they're in training dude
and you just see these guys in their
[ __ ] cockpit whizzing around
passing the [ __ ] out and dude and these
guys are just like all right you ready
yeah all right we're gonna go here we go
and we're gonna go right to six g's and
here we go and the guy goes
dude just immediately dude
immediately
all right and then and then they just
wait dude they're such dicks they just
wait they're just like this and the guy
behind the controls are just waiting and
then the guy goes like this
what happened what happened it feels
like i got in a fight and he's like yeah
well that's what it feels like
you went uh six g's you went six g's
dude
these guys are just [ __ ]
all right here we go
and you get one more shot this was the
one guy was gonna fail if he didn't make
it this last time this was his third try
he wasn't gonna be in the [ __ ] air
force and they're like here we go here
we go we're gonna go
six g's you're not gonna pass out and
here we go one
two and he's
three
four
five and dude he gets to five and he
goes like this
and he's just like this and he goes like
this
he literally goes
okay we're coming down and he gets back
and he's like what happened
he failed
he's not in the air force now dude [ __ ]
all that dude
is
real
and then and then i looked it up on
[ __ ] uh roller coasters people so
people pass out at like three the
g-force of three three g's
and dude some roller coasters go 3.5
dude
that's too dangerous
11 year olds passing the [ __ ] out on a
loop-de-loop
and they're like squeeze your legs
squeeze your legs together tighten your
chest
and tighten your chest and let your
chest go
dude and then i watch these [ __ ] like
blue angels or whatever the hell they're
called um just flying and this one chick
did nine g's dude there was a russian
dude and then a chick a russian dude did
nine g's for 30 seconds and he was just
like yep i'm okay yep i'm okay and he
was like
yep i'm okay
yep good
yup
good
[Music]
and then the chicken then i saw a chick
go in an airplane and did 9.5 g's dude
and she would maybe chicks were better
or whatever but they were just like yeah
i'm good i'm cool yeah i'm great i'm
great yep give me up dude i can't even
believe going nine g's dude how many g's
do you go in an airplane i don't know
two dude i'm good on airplanes man
i would squeeze the [ __ ] out of my
[ __ ] legs and just squeeze the [ __ ]
out of my tummy and breathe
god that sucks to pass out god i would
be [ __ ] terrified
gotta watch some [ __ ] geforce passing
out videos
let's see how dick watch how [ __ ]
matter of i love how matter-of-fact they
are like they know what they're doing
is so pass out
i they know what they're doing here we
go here's the geforce compilation guy
listen
guys literally
here we
go get the lower body nice and tight
breach
one
two stay tight stay tight
good job
hear this guy right here
oh wait this was the one where the guy
was threatened how you doing
oh busted so hard
oh i'm doing all right you know it's all
good dude the [ __ ] way hold on we
gotta watch it that's unbelievable work
hard
three
two one engage
legs tight deep breath
two g's you're on top three eight jeez
nine g's he's got nine g's dude he looks
155 years old because look one
two
three squeeze your legs squeeze your
foot hey okay keep squeezing keep going
keep squeezing watch you pass out so
hard now watch us
okay barely breathe now watch us
are you there
how are you doing
how you doing
i'm good man how you doing
pass the [ __ ] out thinks it's next
tuesday
this guy
is the best one dude
okay i'm so nervous
so nervous okay
oh god the face that they get 100 100
years old and passed the [ __ ] out so
hard what's his next nap and broke his
[ __ ]
discs jesus christ
dying animals
[Music]
oh thrashing
oh a marionette
you doing all right whoa yeah how you
feeling i feel like i was in some sort
of fist fight
oh yeah it looked like that oh so dick
dude you know here's the thing about
these is that [ __ ] these guys they
don't [ __ ] uh
they don't [ __ ] uh
what they're gonna say they don't they
absolutely don't
what the [ __ ] was i gonna say wow it
happened yeah no idea
zero idea what i was gonna say yes took
gabapentin a week ago one time
yes still feeling the effects [ __ ] yeah
dude don't have a [ __ ] clue what i
was gonna say oh dude that rip some 42.
this is the guy that failed
this is the guy that failed
all right we're gonna take it up to 12
g's now
sweet i'm so nervous
sweet
we could do uh eight and a half that's
as high as captain will let us go so
that's your last try so we're gonna
we're gonna get up eight nine eight and
a half just last try are you well we're
gonna get you a title speed first what
listen to him snoring and get moving in
the middle of a
two-month right
okay one g
two g's back on that stick pull back on
the stick let it go there we go now it's
four g's five g6 now we're eight and a
half g's right now nap time relax those
abs drop through shoulders
asleep relax your legs oh he's still
awake deep breath out wow dude
here we go there we go
snort
oh yeah
[Music]
whoa
whoa
uh we're good right i did it
certificate whoa i got
you caught the joke i did about how i
was snoring crazy right
whoa
unreal dude these guys
imagine being an air force pilot dude
have you ever seen [ __ ] shits how
fast they go and they turn quick and
[ __ ] and they whip around and you're
solo up there and you can just literally
look to your left and you just see like
[ __ ] albuquerque like it's not even
like you just literally are in there
it's so small and tight windows here
dude windows here the [ __ ] the the
cover of the thing is literally just an
outline of your body
and it just [ __ ]
covers you and you just look left or
right just
albuquerque right there just look out to
your left and you just see [ __ ] many
many miles down a home depot like that
is insane dude and just pulling jeez up
there dude just [ __ ] bring your stick
back like it's a nut like you're just
edging like you're just edging your [ __ ]
just bringing the stick back just all
[ __ ] 10 000 feet above albuquerque
just edging your [ __ ] stick
you know
trying to get the [ __ ] splurt out
just
30 000 feet up in the air doing twirly
whirlies oh my god dude
forget it just solo doing 90s passing
the [ __ ] out and then you pass out and
then you're playing just doing
loop-de-loops on its own dude is there
anything more terrifying that's why you
have to practice dude that's why you
have to practice in those [ __ ]
training programs that's why you have to
do that
you got to be fit as [ __ ]
you know you got to be fitter [ __ ]
that's why the fat guy failed again he
failed joey i'm fat he failed
um
well fat is in chao young fat's name um
yeah man
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]